eh la verdad que no estaba en mi hoja de ruta
estar aquí hoy
hablando sobre la liderar la lista
el cabildo de coalición canarias
la verdad que llevo un tiempo con annie
de la mano de annie
haciendo un trabajo muy importante en el congreso
y de verdad que no estaba mi hoja de ruta estar aquí
hablando sobre liderar la lista del cabildo
pero la realidad es que no puedo esconder
que me hace muchísima ilusión
eh presentarme a liderar la isla de gran canaria
la isla que me vio nacer
que me vio crecer
eh yo soy gran canaria
no gran canaria ha sido el motivo y la razón
por la cual yo he pausado un momento de mi vida
mi carrera profesional
y me he dedicado a la práctica
y eso sumado pues
a las llamadas y mensajes de muchos compañeros
pues eh ha sido determinante para que hoy esté aquí
y dé un paso al frente
y me presente a la lista del cabildo
colección canaria para liderar un proyecto nuevo
para realmente darle un vuelco al cabildo
tenemos la concepción del cabildo de gran canaria
como el lugar
donde los políticos van a terminar su vida política
y yo creo que no que hay que darle una vuelta
hay que modernizarlo
hay que meter gente nueva
con ganas y con ganas de cambiar las cosas
y realmente tenemos un gobierno de la isla
muy importante con muchas herramientas
con muchas capacidades de hacer cosas
para cambiar la vida de las personas
tiene dinero y competencias para cambiar vidas
en todos los estamentos sociales
jóvenes mayores autónomos
empleo tenemos una cifra de empleo de paro juvenil
el 47% el más alto de 8h islas
tenemos realmente una situación sociosanitaria
muy límite y lo mejor de todo
coliseum cana
que lleva mucho tiempo
haciendo un proyecto que se llama
eh colisión canaria
eh canarias te necesita y en en ese marco
hemos hecho muchísimas reuniones con el gran canario
te necesita hemos contactado con la sociedad civil
y colisión canaria tiene un proyecto para esta
para esta isla
y me encantaría y me haría muchísima ilusión liderarlo
y por eso hoy
les he convocado para decirles que me voy a presentar
encabezar la lista al cabildo por este partido
porque la verdad
que el cabiño
y el empuje de los compañeros y líderes
y lideresas locales
pues han hecho que fuera determinante
y además de la ilusión que por supuesto
sobra decir que
que que va intrínseca en mi proyecto no